this is a production of cornell
university uh thanks everybody
this is the uh 18th episode of the
cornell turf show this spring
uh happy to have a guest dr ben mcgraw
the penn state university we're at a
bunch of penn state guests here frank in
the last couple weeks
we don't know how we feel about that but
uh we're excited to have ben on today to
talk about
i'm sure annual bluegrass weevil crane
flies we'll talk about a whole
host of bugs here um but a quick
announcement for everybody uh
frank and i are gonna extend this uh
turf show series one extra week for
everybody it's the old
buy ten get one free uh everybody's
really enjoyed these things so we're
gonna go
one more week for our live audience and
of course you'll be able to get that
on on video or podcast as well but um as
always we'll start out frank uh
lead us off here okay carl
thanks very much it's so great to be
here uh
hi to everyone thanks for ben and and
and big
shout out to nelson karen and and and
absolutely what looked like a gem
i don't know the rest of the golf course
but the holes i saw along the
shore it's the first good look i really
took the time to take a look at seminole
and
absolutely spectacular venue of course
uh
you know with uh gill's hand gil hans's
hands on a good cornell grad there
uh helping make a great golf course
better so uh tom feller out in
in cedar rapids iowa celebrating his
grandson coming to the
golf course uh so exciting when
everybody can share
uh the passion of of taking care of the
land and the course with their family
and then of course this was the week of
broken stuff right i i had as many mower
broken pictures and
pictures as i've seen anywhere and i
love the picture on the right that came
with the caption
uh irrigation parts for sale some
assembly required i just
i love seeing that stuff and then i
couldn't help but chuckle
uh recently i've been getting around the
state again as people start
moving out of new york city uh and into
the rest of the part of the state
um you know most of us think of you know
downstate
anything south of that pennsylvania
northern pennsylvania border oh no you
must be from new york city
but i can tell you just you know from as
a downstate person
also if you're from westchester county
you're from upstate so
uh it's a very different perspective and
i love the western new york they don't
even call it soda
they call it pop that was a big learning
thing for me uh
shout out to john hoyle at corning
country club uh doing tree work right i
know gary player is shooting his mouth
off these days
saying man we need all these trees and i
just want you to focus in this lovely
before and after picture that john took
you know what's wrong with seeing your
golf course right
i don't see what's wrong with actually
seeing your golf course right
and presumably this isn't a safety
hazard or or that sort of thing you know
but but you know i don't see what's
wrong with being able to see your golf
course and
in the news we can tell jim brosnan out
in tennessee and matt elmore down at
rutgers
uh you know they all got together and
and each year vote on
you know it's like the academy awards or
something for weed scientists
and and this year uh the survey of grass
crops uh pasture and turf
released their most troublesome and most
common weeds
that they find there and and you can see
crabgrass dandelion at the top annual
bluegrass
both in most common and most troublesome
and most troublesome
uh where is where it's difficult to
control so you can see clover doesn't
necessarily transfer over
because it's generally perceived as and
dandelion generally perceived as
relatively easy to control
all right carl here we are again with
our environmental research program
update with
our project with rit rick slattery uh
highlighting adoption of bmps obviously
you can go to the sustainability website
uh that we've got through the pollution
prevention institute and carl we even
shipped out a poster
that you were kind enough to post with a
picture for and take us through the bmp
tip of the week
yeah so you know as we've been making
our way through this poster
uh during our show this week uh this
year frank uh you know we've gotten a
little bit on the nutrient management
side but today i wanted to highlight
one of the things one of our eagle sort
of practices here is measuring clipping
volume
the greens are the most intense
management area on golf courses and it
makes sense to be really
precise and accurate about when we're
applying fertilizer why we're doing that
and clipping volume is an easy way to do
it we just wrote a little
uh article in the gcsa ny newsletter
about it
i'll put the link to uh below the video
here to our live audience if you want to
check it out but clipping volume is
really easy you just dump the grass that
you measure
that you mow off on greens you just dump
it into a bucket and you keep that
number
and some data here for our folks uh
watching this is from the robert
jones golf course their fifth green the
first year that
the superintendent dave hicks started
collecting clipping volumes this orange
line
uh and you can see there's some big
swings in here right so big swings in
growth
uh that was happening a lot um that year
because we had some big
heavy rainfall events one after the
other and we would see
growth spikes after that and and as you
all would imagine growth spikes lead to
less than ideal playing conditions slow
wet surfaces
uh and if we go really quickly back
there frank to the blue line is the 2019
data
after dave had kind of a year under his
belt of looking at that growth data you
can see
that blue line's a lot more steady
there's a couple there's a couple humps
in there that just aren't controllable
due to environmental conditions but
that gray zone this sort of goldilocks
zone is what we're calling it
where he got good playing conditions
growth was very steady and you can see
in that second year
and the subsequent years after he's been
able to keep
his green surfaces in that sort of ideal
zone a little bit more
um and this translates out to the
playing conditions right so there is
that link a lot of superintendents
noticing that link between
how much their greens grow and how well
their surfaces perform
of course we know the stim meter chris
tritibal wrote a really nice article
again i'll post that in the description
here
just talking about the step meter and i
know it's the bane of a lot of
superintendent's existence but
if you use it for your own good you can
start to connect okay green speed with
growth
and growth is something we can tangibly
try to
affect right we have fertilizers we have
pgrs
cultural practices our mowing rolling
frequency
uh you know green speeds it's a little
bit harder to directly manage that but
because we have this link between green
speeds and growth now that we're seeing
using this data if it matters measure
um we can we can come up with better
green surfaces and in chris's case he
says i don't have to put as much effort
into it because i'm measuring these
things
it's easier for me so that's our bmp tip
of the day
thanks carl love that stuff and and one
of the things
uh another uh news item is the the
re uh visiting of the uh new of the
normal temperatures every 10 years noah
revises normal and so when we say
relative to normal in our weather
records here here in
in our forecast website at cornell we
usually use the 30-year average so
you're looking at
30-year average temperatures from the
beginning of the 20th century to the end
of the 20th century
uh where you can see temperatures going
up pretty high
and and even in the last uh since 1981
the period
between 81 and 2010 and 91 and 2020
you can see that we've continued to warm
so i do think
not just measuring uh you know not just
paying attention to the fact that it's
warming but having the clippings there
uh as a measurement of how things are
changing
you know when carl when you say chris
isn't worrying about it that's very
telling it's like
data where many people worry about
having data
in many cases having this data can help
you explain things even to yourself
right and and makes it easier for you to
manage these things so let's get into
the weather
as we see it nowadays and and one of the
things that we've noticed is we're in a
bit of a stall
we were way ahead of normal for a period
of time and and except for balmy buffalo
uh we continue to be right at about
normal relative to growing degree days
but the uh temperature prognostication
moving forward is
more likely to be above normal uh in the
next couple of weeks now
again we know we we always take these
things a little bit at
you know uh you know with with some
skepticism about projecting out we
haven't always been
as reliable but it appears that the
trends now for these above normal
temperatures are are going to be pretty
solid
um and that's going to start to drive
soil temperature you'll notice
we have soil temperatures still in the
areas in the 40s
at the 2 inch depth and we were almost
across the board well into the 50s and
60s
uh over the last couple of weeks so just
like last year
we hit a little bit of the stall pattern
and it looks like we're about to break
out of it now
on on the rainfall front you know at
least where i am i got plenty
i don't really need anymore where we are
i think maybe buckley
rich buckley might have come and visit
us here in central new york and central
pa
over the last week because we got plenty
of rain not everybody experienced that
but almost everybody got
some but we're expecting a dry period
now
uh for the next couple of weeks anyway
moving forward
now ben as we start to talk about annual
bluegrass weevil i just want to remind
you of this great work that you guys did
a while ago that served as the basis for
us to
work with our state park guys in our
state park funded project
over the years to especially the beth
page guys but really everybody
talking to them about the way they apply
and see damage and manage their annual
bluegrass weevil and i know you've
you know done work at bethpage and paid
attention to some of the things that
we've been able to do with jennifer
grant over the years and carl's keeping
it up
scouting record keeping choosing the
right materials
and how that resulted in over a period
of time
a significant reduction in environmental
risk
area treated and number of applications
made per year so
it was really good that you did that
publication with albrecht a number of
years ago
but recently it looks like you're
bringing up some stuff that you might
have done either at delhi or not long
after you
uh got the delhi ban and i want to bring
you on here for a minute i'm going to
make make it so everybody can see i want
to keep the slides up
because i want to talk to you a little
bit about emergence now pal
this is what you saw back then i i
pulled these two out of the publication
one a two peak one a one peak right you
talk about multi-volt
you know uh multi uh german you know
volting
multi-volting love that word gonna try
to get that and scrabble somewhere see
if i can get that into the scrabble
tournament so talk a little bit about
how
how much you like this trend of tracking
degree days as a good way of scouting
or if you don't uh tell me why you know
it's maybe not a good way to go but
talk to us a little bit about emergence
because it looks like we're in the teeth
of it now
yeah i would expect that you would be
and i do talk to quite a few turf grass
managers in
upstate new york on a weekly basis and
and what they're seeing and what we're
seeing
um you know this is a paper that i did
do at delhi and then we finished up some
stuff later on
to cap it all off but uh you know the
first thing that i want to talk about
in relation to this work is growing
degree day calculations
um so part of you know syntensa's weeble
track is that we have researchers across
the northeast to contribute data and
you know since that time you know since
the i guess that was right
around that 2011 time um
i i didn't really do weevil track until
i came to penn state in 2014
but before that time we were all using a
standard
uh growing degree day monitor the
spectrum technologies monitor
and so right immediately whenever i show
slide like as people will put these
numbers down
that these are concrete things and i do
want to mention right out of the gate
like
this is the instrument that we used and
the method that is being used to
calculate these growing degree days is a
simplified
sine method so like a sine function
which accounts for
you know number of hours above a certain
threshold and numbers below
uh if you were to just get your weather
station at an
airport to give you a max and min
and you freehand calculated that these
numbers would be drastically different
drastically driving yourself i think so
okay uh especially in the spring uh when
we need these
data to mean something uh so often
you know people contact me through
twitter or call me and and say you know
i'm at 350 growing degree days and
it doesn't really make a whole lot of
sense so there are some limitations to
these data
i wish it wasn't the case i wish it was
like you know
these numbers were the numbers but okay
all right well listen that's good
yeah i think it's good i think it's good
to clarify
so because a lot of people as we onboard
more people to data-driven stuff ben
it's important to tell them that not all
data's is
as clean as a baby's butt right it's not
it's not all really clean right
there's a lot of it that just needs a
lot of cleansing and and so
i think more importantly the question is
you like
tracking the degree days is one
component
but i'm interested in the pattern of
behavior here because that's where i'm
going to
just let you know where i'm going to is
maybe the shifting that we're getting to
ben in monitoring uh
adults and then the way you dissected
these things
looked at eggs the way you looked at new
food in their gut
and you know the questions for today and
we can go back and forth with the slides
and we can just look at each other but
my question is
you know i really think that insecticide
resistance
is building and i'm wondering if you
think that's part of what's motivated
you lately
to understand this larval strategy a
little bit more
uh are we gonna get new products and i
guess let's start
you know where we're at this year right
so let let's start with the
stuff where are we at this year and then
uh we'll talk about sort of in general
uh how the paper went
okay so where we are this year very
weird year i know you guys are really
good about the updates of weather
and that is exactly what we saw uh so we
start tracking growing degree days and i
do like growing degree days and we have
an
extensive data set for many of our sites
i think we've done some larval
extractions that are better that make
our models better here at penn state
so this year i would have bet money that
i could have
in my remote office pull the trigger for
different
applications around around the region
and you know we had built this great
data set the r
square value was awesome uh you know so
it explained the data beautifully
and then absolutely [ __ ] the bed
as far as the models breaking down so
like where i was like oh man we gotta
publish this it's like all of a sudden i
couldn't explain it
mostly from the adults so we start
tracking
uh march first you know that's an
arbitrary number
uh we did do some things on campus where
we bought some
in-ground sensors that we could access
remotely and we started those back in
december at the solstice
you know just to see if we were missing
anything and i think like as you move
south you know obviously you could have
insects emerging before march 1st
what we saw this year is we had a very
dry
and very warm early march and so just
like
all the beer that i like to drink there
might be empty calories there might be
empty growing degree days in there as
well
and so i think what happened in those
first two weeks of march
we were accumulating these growing
degree days but it might not have been
the sole explanation about why things
move and develop
you know these things happen at regular
times every year you know if we had a
model with
temperature and maybe daily um maybe
that would
smooth things out maybe there's moisture
component we don't know
but our models are very very simple and
they're based on temperature
in spring is where we're going to see
all our variability um
so we have you know larval
models as well and all of a sudden
because of this cool cooldown
i think we're starting to align back
with the models so what we're seeing
here
you know we started picking up first and
second in stars
at our columbus ohio site all the way to
harrisburg last week
it's about 30 growing degree days above
what the model would predict but 30
growing degree days could be two
relatively warm days okay so so you've
already made the transition to talking
about larvae because further south where
this pest has traveled
obviously it's it's it's further it's
further advanced
but again to remind everybody the goal
with tracking these adults
is to lower the population so they can't
breed
correct and drop eggs that overwhelms
our ability to maybe try to get him as
larvae and we'll get to try to control
the second generation
later on in the show but for now let's
just stay there
okay how much longer how much longer do
you see
i mean adult aside strategies still
remain the cornerstone
or i know you've warned me about this in
the past going to a larval
only strategy so talk to me about where
you still sit on the value of trying to
time
at peak emergence to drop that number
yeah i mean i think it's it's a big part
of the programs i
i consult with multiple golf courses
throughout the region
uh and all of those properties
we do put out an adult aside it is a
the only time of the year where you're
going to have one stage present
it's above ground it's susceptible you
can do
things where you can get control however
control is not perfect
what we're looking to do is just take a
chunk out of the population
and we're also trying to really reduce
that egg laying window
so in that study that you referenced we
tracked individuals
over a couple of years you know like
same male
and female in their little uh little
poet prison
and we would move them each week and i'd
count the egg so that's what i was doing
all this morning before this show
uh in those individuals we had females
that would live 15 weeks
so like if you're talking uh in upstate
new york and april 1st emergence
they could be laying eggs all the way
into july if you could keep them alive
they have
they have the potential to do that so
will they lay i mean
so does that necessarily mean with their
ability to do that if you don't lower
their numbers
that there's you're just going to be
overwhelmed constantly with larval
and then and then that of course begs
the question is it the same thing with
larvae that you're just taking a chunk
out you're not
you know cleaning house yeah so they're
going to naturally get on
asynchronous or unsynchronized uh in the
summer populations and
i do think that you know the majority if
you look at that paper the majority of
eggs are laid between
five and eight weeks and in confinement
uh
are adults living that long out in the
wild they're probably getting picked off
by other
insects or birds or getting hit by
mowers
so that might that's like a best case
scenario to some degree
however even if we take the conservative
side and go eight weeks of egg laying
they're laying eggs all through may and
into june if they're not being
controlled
and you're just leading to the jumbled
stages much earlier in the year
which is impossible to control within
any chemical strategy
okay uh so what we're trying to do is
reduce that egg laying window
but also synchronize the future larval
population so
again the courses that i consult with uh
we're
following that adult aside with a
larvicide
after that they're not just is there is
is there evidence ben that do you know
the size of the chunk
you get do you know the size of the
chunk
that you need to get you know i mean we
never talk thresholds with a b
i've never heard a word about thresholds
with these things but when we start
talking about the way we're doing this
now
you know obviously that's my first
question let's start there
do we do we know how much we have to
reduce it and is
are we just making sure we're hitting it
at the peak do you tell
guys to keep tracking after they spray
to see what happens to numbers
let's talk a little bit about that for a
second and then and then we're going to
get to
life without chlorpyrifos yeah so uh
yeah i mean ideally um you know if i
were
each population is like a snowflake and
because of pyrethroid resistance and and
you said you think that it's
it's becoming more and more a problem i
think it's already there
i would say uh you know i think we have
some evidence from my graduate student
that that's page is actually getting
better from
laying off of it that uh he's looking at
some microbiome stuff which is a
story for another time and we're seeing
some changes in the microbiome so
there's some interesting things that we
have to stay tuned for but
i think we've already maxed out um with
pyrethroid resistance i think there's a
lot of places in the metropolitan new
york area
that are dealing with you know three
decades of pyrethroid use
uh and they don't think that they have a
problem but when we test them and
you know we just had a test last week
and it was like these are
these are pretty tolerant um so that
chunk might be as little as 25 to 30
percent
um but in that paper with the two peaks
in some years
um that could be just what we're seeing
this year with a warm-up
they come out but not all of them have
emerged and we get that cool down and
then there's another
emergence so that can affect things as
well that's why it's hard to say
the adulticide being the cornerstone
because it's really a one-two punch
and both of them are important uh i
think we've got some great products for
larvicides
however you know to just rely on
larvicides
it's not something that i would
recommend if somebody's hosting
a big event or wants to keep their job
in height
okay so so let's get to uh
resistance right uh pyrethroid
resistance we've maybe maxed out maybe
it's improving if you lay off of it
that's
a certainly a message about rotation and
and that sort of thing but you'd think
that'd be a message for that
i'm wondering about you know products
that are on the market now
that can work as adulticides or you see
them
maybe having a role as larvicides but
we've never thought of them as such and
of course i'm thinking about a celebrant
because a lot of guys are going out for
grub control in the next couple of weeks
and maybe there's a twofer there
what what do you think about these sort
of not traditional materials for
adulticides
to use them in that strategy yeah i mean
i think you're
alluding to our work with uh civitas and
we're hopefully going to get those
papers out
uh it's off of my plate my co-authors
have to step up and play
all the cuff and offer but uh
you know we've looked at those products
we've looked at surfactants we've done a
lot of work with surfactants
this spring you know all of the
surfactants
that we test have some sort of um
lethal action against uh these insects
if you think about combining these
things with some traditional products
we we have some studies uh where we've
already pulled off the data from
early collections of adults with looking
at surfactants in combination with
pyrethroids
against pyrethroid resistant populations
surfactants and chlorpyrifos against
some pretty resistant populations
and we see some really dynamite
combinations with insecticides but all
of them
well not all of them i'll say a good
deal of them
will provide some level of mortality if
you can
spray the insect directly so it could be
a suffocation
in the case of civitas we know that it's
kind of breaking down surface tension
and kind of flooding them from the
inside
but in the case of mixing it with a
pyrethroid
um you know if you think about the
outside of the insect it's got a waxy
cuticle so it's
hydrophobic to begin with what we think
is happening there's plenty of
evidence in the literature about using
pyrethroids with surfactants against
resistant populations
that it allows for better delivery into
the insects so some of these insects
that develop
physiological resistance they have
thicker cuticles and stuff like that
uh we really don't know uh despite what
entomologists will tell you we really
don't know what drives resistance in
these insects
i mean there were some studies uh where
they applied
certain things and make the assumption
that it's enzymes and
there's a good possibility that it could
be enzyme driven however these
these populations don't mix much so to
say that there's only one
uh mode of resistance is is kind of a
leap
and so yeah so thanks for
bringing up modes of action modes of
resistance
because i'm wondering are there you know
we suffer in the weed world from the
lack of new chemistries and
and modes of action and and weeds are
going to continue
you know matt elmore was on here a
couple weeks ago and was saying you got
to be creative
weeds are starting to figure out ways
around our pre-emergent crabgrass
control and we've got new weeds causing
problems
are there new chemistries on the horizon
for abw
that that maybe are being developed that
we're not seeing in the
in the weed world yeah i think um
ironically we i think with the loss of
floor paraphos is a big one for abw
and new york still everywhere else in
the world
and you know the popular again the
courses i consult with i'd say we're
probably
mostly using chlorpyrifos for that
adulticide spray
doesn't feel great to recommend it it's
probably something we shouldn't be using
but it's highly efficacious even against
these
uh populations so we can make it work
really well
yeah i don't like recommending it
uh however i do think this is the last
year that i will be recommending it
because there are new products coming on
board
so i guess i'm free to speak about this
now but there is going to be a new
product that we were trying to get in
your hands down at the beth page place
that
is about the most exciting thing i've
seen in my career
oh it's going to be an insect growth
regulator
from csi or quali pro or adama they're
all
kind of intertwined but i think quali
pro's the
company that will be the face to the
superintendent
um what we see is pretty amazing
activity against
larvae it's a growth regulator so it
didn't hit it's
molting so if you apply it against a
larva
it's not going to make it to the next
instar we've looked at it when they're
in the plant
out of the plant dynamite control with
one application
per year but what makes it the most
exciting thing that i think i've seen in
my career is what it does to the adults
and you know just coming back from the
lab and we've looked at this for a
couple years we're gonna
get a paper out this later this year on
this when we apply it against the adults
it affects their ability to legs which
is like
my number one wish list is if you could
control
something none of our products control
eggs so you
can control the thing that doesn't lay
eggs you know
it's good now there may be some problems
with its lack of
selectivity you know if it's be a
molting inhibitor that
could have it you know we're going to
look at that as well
you know we want to cover all our bases
but the good thing about abw
is it's the dominant insect out there
golf courses where we have abw
problems so uh there might be a few
things that get caught in the crosshairs
but very low toxicity i think carl you
look that up for your
your work at bethpage and it that's
pretty exciting appeals of that i think
we've got a couple more products that i
can't talk about right now that are
coming down the pipeline as well so
we don't have a whole lot of products in
the insect world yeah
very few classes you go to canada give a
talk in canada
i reduce 75 percent of what we have here
and then i'm about to get on a call with
the uk after this
and they've got one insecticide they
only have a celebrity well and and the
whole neo-nick uh
the whole neonic concern of course the
banning of chlorpyrifos in new york
state
uh is is uh manifested to that so carl
we are at the 10 30 hour you know we
could go on for a while are there any
questions or comments from you or the
crew
yeah i think one thing i'd ask you ben
is um you know with abw
it seems like chemical control really is
is our only option
short of changing grasses right annual
bluegrass if you get the po
out of there are there any other
non-chemical
uh control methods for people who maybe
don't have the budget to spray their
fairways who are getting hammered
um yeah i mean i think uh i do think
like um
the poa selectivity is an issue that i'd
like to address and and
i have a phd students working on the
bench problem so
it very readily attacks bent grass we're
throwing it on bermuda we're throwing it
on rye
uh i think the the insect is going to
want to survive when it moves into these
new areas
and we see it do just fine in bent grass
um
so i think there was some recent studies
from my little laboratory where they're
trying to use it as a selective tool
i i i
i'm gonna disrespectfully disagree
okay yeah yeah yeah because that is
something i think um
uh uh matt elmore had a grad student
working on it
uh for selectivity um and i i think
that's a
very interesting approach we've seen it
work a little bit in places at bethpage
but
as you've said and in the mid-atlantic
and ask the guys down there
they're eating the you know stan zontek
saw him eating the bent grass
10 15 years ago was talking about 20 or
more
right yeah so we've known about that for
a long time and
um yeah i think you have a higher safety
net i mean we did those papers
back in the early 2000s at records so um
yeah hey it's it's
it's worth looking at but uh i don't
think of that as really a viable
opportunity
i mean i i do think it does give you a
higher safety net i don't think it's
gonna eliminate it
uh and maybe that's all you need i mean
you just need to play defense against
damage
that's right um you know our cultural
practices that we've looked at
nitrogen doesn't have an impact on this
insect
uh it's you know we have an its paper
coming out on that
rolling and mowing and brushing all of
those things have
uh impact on them and it can be a
significant impact but that's really
only gonna
reduce the load on uh greens
so you're not gonna go out you know and
and the heights that we're mowing even
at callers doesn't really
remove any of these insects either so
uh you know i did my phd on nematodes
and
they're highly effective but i don't
know signal course is
using my research there so well yeah and
and listen carl if there's no questions
that is a perfect way to end because i
do think we're seeing the same issues
with um we're seeing the same issues
with with any place we're trying to use
nematodes where school districts
you know are having grub problems but
the community's getting tired of the
routine exemptions
for even something like a celebrant they
the the resistance in new york state ben
uh to pesticide use uh continues to grow
at a more rapid rate than insect
resistant does
uh to the pesticide so thanks for taking
the time to join us carl
we don't want to bend the space-time
continuum too much we're at the
30-minute thing
it's so great to see you ben thanks for
taking the time thanks for having me
right i agree with vanessa allen's
coffee brandy for everyone
yeah invite us another another classic
comment there um
thanks everyone for joining us we'll be
back tomorrow grady miller will have him
on to talk about mower performance stuff
he's
researched in the past so don't miss
that until then we'll see you guys later
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu